[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing severus snape
voldemort and horcruxes more
specifically
we're going to be discussing whether or
not snape was aware
of the fact that voldemort had created
horcruxes
voldemort's key to immortality
voldemort's creation of horcruxes
which are arguably one of the darkest
and most twisted forms of magic
started off with just a misguided young
boy unsure of his place in the world
tom riddle was an orphan abandoned by
his mother at wool's orphanage before he
ever got a chance to know her his
existence was a tragedy
and the only reason that he was ever
birthed at all was because his mother
had used a love potion on his father
when the effects of the love potion were
off tom middle senior
immediately left murapi and this meant
that tom riddle
started off his life with nothing but
abandonment
after years at the orphanage dumbledore
eventually discovered the young riddle
and brought him to the world's finest
magical school
while a student at hogwarts riddle was
very impressive
and he expressed an unparalleled ability
to learn
he constantly asked questions and he
didn't want to leave any stoner interned
when it came to the wizarding world
there is one particular branch of magic
however that captivated riddle and it's
a form of magic that he certainly should
have never discovered
that magic involves horcruxes objects in
which dark witches or wizards
have imbued part of their soul the
ultimate purpose of creating the horcrux
is to achieve
immortality however the truly sinister
component of creating horcrux
is that in order to produce one you must
murder someone
as he grew older and as he learned more
about horcruxes he began to create them
for himself
and eventually he had many being one of
only two known wizards
to have created them at one point in
time severus snape was a full-fledged
death eater
and devoted servant of the dark lord
disgusted with the actions of the
quote-unquote
good guys and fueled by the torment that
he'd endured for much of his upbringing
snape turned to the dark side and became
one of voldemort's right-hand men
in fact it was snape himself that
overheard sybil trolloni discussing the
fabled prophecy
and snape 2 who relayed the message to
voldemort
the two were close snape trusted
voldemort and voldemort trusted snape
but that all changed when lily evan's
life was in danger
given that snape was in voldemort's
inner circle for so many years
and that he had formed such a close bond
with him i always wondered
was snape aware of voldemort's horcraxes
and if not why wasn't he snape was a
bonafide magical genius
and he knew more about magic than almost
every other wizard
in the wizarding world having gone down
the rabbit hole of both sides of the
wizarding spectrum
good and bad not only that but he was a
master legilimens
a master of the mind he knew exactly how
to read people
how to analyze their behaviors and
patterns how could he have missed
powerful dark magic
at play the truth is snape didn't know
about voldemort's horcruxes
but it's not because he wasn't observant
or because he did anything wrong
he simply missed them because he didn't
know what they were
horcruxes are one of the darkest forms
of magic and the number of witches
wizards aware of their existence is
infinitesimal
the only reason that tom riddle was
lucky enough to have learned more about
them
is because horace slughorn was his
teacher who
just so happened to have some info about
them
in fact slughorn's inadvertent guidance
was undoubtedly instrumental in
voldemort's rise to power
though snape had delved deep into the
dark gods horcruxes aren't exactly a
common topic
even in the realm of dark magic that's
how taboo
the subject is when hermione searches
for the books in the restricted section
none of them give details on horcruxes
and only one of them
even mentioned horcruxes i haven't found
one single explanation of what horcruxes
do
she told him not a single one i've been
right through the restricted section
and even in the most horrible books
where they tell you how to brew the most
gruesome potions
nothing all i could find was this in the
introduction
to magic most evil listen of the horcrux
wickedest of magical inventions we shall
not speak
nor give direction i mean why mention it
then
she said impatiently slamming the old
book shut
it let out a ghostly whale oh shut up
she snapped stuffing it back into her
bag
furthermore dumbledore himself expressed
that he didn't believe the existence of
horcruxes
to be known by any of the death eaters
some of which may have known
more about dark magic specifically than
snape
then you told me two years later that on
the night that voldemort returned to his
body
he made a most illuminating and alarming
statement to his death eaters
i who have gone further than anybody
along the path that leads to immortality
that was what you told me he said
further than anybody
and i thought i knew what that meant
though the death eaters did not
he was referring to his horcruxes
horcruxes in the plural harry
which i do not believe any other wizard
has ever had it was an area of magic
that was generally unknown
entirely uncharted even lucius malfoy
a dark wizard that dove into some of the
darkest forms of magic and boasted about
it
knew nothing of voldemort's horcruxes he
was a magical object
expert yet he was unable to recognize
the properties
of a certain magical object in his
possession tom riddle's
diary of course lucius did not know what
the diary really was
i understand that voldemort had told him
the diary would cause the chamber of
secrets to reopen
because it was cleverly enchanted had
lucius known he held a portion of his
master's soul in his hands
he would undoubtedly have treated it
with more reverence
but instead he went ahead and carried
out the old plan
for his own ends by planting the diary
upon arthur weasley's daughter
he hoped to discredit arthur have me
thrown out of hogwarts
and get rid of a highly incriminating
object in one stroke
furthermore it makes perfect sense that
voldemort would avoid mentioning
horcruxes altogether
why would he reveal any kind of
information about the objects
that ensured he remained immortal
discussing them would only prompt
curiosity and in turn lead to further
investigation
which would jeopardize his position as
much as snape was an all-knowing
tactician
that you couldn't get anything past we
have to remember that so was voldemort
he didn't become one of the most
powerful dark wizards to have ever lived
by accident he like snape was fueled by
a childhood full of abandonment and
strife
allowing him to dive into magic driven
and undistracted
motivated additionally the timing at
which both voldemort and snape
attended hogwarts is of utmost
importance here's the thing
the majority of the knowledge that
voldemort initially gathered on
horcruxes
did actually come from the hogwarts
library however
we also know that by the time harry goes
to hogwarts there are no books to be
found
that broached the topic so where did
these books go
we need to remember that when tom riddle
started at hogwarts
dumbledore was still just a professor
which meant that he was not yet in
charge of the school
however dumbledore did eventually become
headmaster
and it was at this point that he removed
all books from the hogwarts library
mentioning horcruxes fully aware of the
destruction that they can bring in the
wrong hands
well said hermione i've been researching
that how
asked harry i didn't think there were
any books on horcruxes in the library
there weren't said hermione who had
turned pink dumbledore removed them all
but he he didn't destroy them in short
though snape had the same affinity for
learning as voldemort
he didn't have access to the same dark
materials growing up
which meant that he never learned of the
horcrux wickedest of magical inventions
and that's it for this video did you
guys ever think about this
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
there is plenty to be learned even from
a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be
[Music]
you